handel und für treffen
schritt 2 dann lockerungen für
gastronomie und großveranstaltungen und
am ende dann bleibt nur die maske in bus
und bahn das alles wenn die situation in
den krankenhäusern ist zulässt so haben
es bund und länder heute beschlossen
auch wenn wir corona damit noch nicht
ganz hinter uns haben und brauchen wir
dann eigentlich noch eine impfpflicht
neue krone regeln locker in den frühling
unser thema in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
es geht ja vielen bürgerinnen und
bürgern sowie mir irgendwie haben wir
nach all diesen lang zwei jahren zwei
jahren auch mal
verdient dass es irgendwie wieder besser
wird und es sieht ein bisschen danach
aus dass wir genau das auch vor uns
haben ja das ist ein optimistischer
bundeskanzler nach dem treffen heute mit
den bundesländern herzlich willkommen
aus berlin zu dieser phoenix runde über
die neue normalität da spreche ich mit
diesen gästen bei uns ist linda
teuteberg für die fdp im bundestag und
sie unterstützt den antrag gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht und ich begrüße
junger stammen gesundheitspolitischer
sprecher von bündnis 90/die grünen er
hat als arzt bis november 2020 in den
bundestag kam den rettungsdienst hier in
berlin geleitet und er spricht sich mit
anderen abgeordneten für einen antrag
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18
jahren aus und ich begrüße ganz herzlich
frank ulrich montgomery er ist
vorsitzender des welt ärzte bundes
schlucken abend und michael broeker
chefredakteur von chefredakteur von
media polonia normalerweise ist er auf
dem redaktions schiff hier auf der spree
unterwegs jetzt in münchen zugeschaltet
schönen guten abend
bot heute berg ist er ist der 20 märz
ist das jetzt deutschlands freedom day
es ist hoffentlich auf jeden fall der
tag an dem beginnt das jede maßnahme
auch wieder begründet werden muss oder
eben wegfällt und das ist richtig so die
ampel koalition hatte er auch bewusst
ein enddatum zunächst beschlossen für
das infektionsschutzgesetz eine
besondere regelung und jetzt muss auch
jede maßnahme wegfallen die nicht mehr
notwendig ist und das gilt doch für die
meisten maßnahmen insofern so locker wie
möglich so vorsichtig wie nötig damit
sie gehören ja eigentlich eher immer zum
team vorsicht an sie bauchschmerzen
jetzt bei diesen lockerungen wenn es
heißt eigentlich ab 20 märz okay die
maske noch in innenräumen aber sonst
brauchen wir nichts mehr ja zunächst mal
können wir heute feststellen und das ist
ein gutes signal dass es uns gelungen
ist in den letzten wochen mit einem
ausgewogenen maß an schutz maßnahmen
dafür zu sorgen dass nicht allzu viele
menschen krank geworden sind in dieser
mikrowelle dass wir trotz hoher
fallzahlen keine neuerliche schwere
überlastung im gesundheitswesen gesehen
haben und dass wir jetzt an einem punkt
sind wo die fallzahlen nicht weiter
steigen und wir deswegen eine geplante
vorausschauende perspektive von
stufenweisen lockerungen angehen können
die immer an objektive indikatoren
gekoppelt werden müssen bevor wir eine
nächste stufe gehen klar ist auch am 20
märz wird die pandemie nicht vorbei sein
so dass wir sicherlich auch über dieses
datum hinaus
schutzmaßnahmen brauchen werden um
sicher in den frühling zu kommen darüber
gehen wir gleich noch was man dann doch
noch braucht da gibt es ja auch wünsche
von den ländern hermann connery wie sehr
freuen sie sich auf einen frühling ohne
corona maßnahmen oder haben sie auf der
anderen seite eben auch bedenken das ist
dann doch zu locker wird
naja die bedenken die hat man man ja
immer aber wir haben doch bisher
bewiesen dass er die immer auch durch
mahnung und ähnliches einfangen konnten
ich freue mich auf den öfters früher
hatte ich freue mich darauf dass wir
heute bei inzidenz von
1400 über lockerungen reden können das
zeigt wie gut unsere bevölkerung
inzwischen immunisiert ist da kann man
zwar noch ein bisschen mehr machen
deswegen bin ich auch für die
impfpflicht aber wir sind eigentlich in
deutschland sehr gut dabei und ich hoffe
dass es uns jetzt nur gelingt nicht
nachzulassen nicht nachlässig zu werden
um dann auch dass die die nächsten
winter und die nächsten herbst gut zu
bestehen herr brücke was denken sie was
hat denn jetzt eigentlich diesen den
ausschlag gegeben für diese lockerung
ist es sozusagen der gesellschaftliche
druck weil im ausland ja auch überall
gelockert wird oder ist es eher die
erkenntnis ok mit dieser mikrowelle das
können wir hinkriegen mit den aus
vitalisierung raten jetzt trauen wir uns
das
ganz ehrlich frau prettner ich glaube
fakten und der gesunde menschenverstand
denn die wahrheit ist doch dass wir uns
nicht in der nationalen lager
epidemische tragweite mehr befinden oder
in einer nationalen lage endemisch
ertrag weiter die fallzahlen sinken die
sterblichkeitsrate sinkt seit sieben
wochen die hospitalisierung since it
ends von der müsste man eigentlich zwei
drittel der zahlen abziehen weil viele
dieser patienten 80 prozent teilweise in
kliniken ja in die krankenhäuser in die
intensivstation kommen und zufällig auch
krone positiv sind all diese zahlen sind
doch evident und da muss man doch
irgendwann mal sagen wir können freiheit
beschränkende maßnahmen nicht mehr
aufrecht halte ich würde mich eher warum
es erst so spät kommt früher haben die
liberalen immer gesagt die freiheit
stirbt scheibchenweise ich finde die
freiheit kommt jetzt scheibchenweise
zurück und aus meiner sicht sogar zu
spät die wohlhabenden gruppen sind mit
90 prozent gut geimpft das war immer das
zentrale das zentrale argument die
hospitalisierung traten ich habe es ja
angesprochen es gibt keine überlastung
in den intensivstationen nur zehn
prozent der intensivbetten sind von
corona patienten besetzt insofern und
wie gesagt da muss man die zahlen dann
auch nochmal differenziert betrachten
aus meiner sicht gibt es keine
wirklichen argumente mehr für harte
freiheitseinschränkende maßnahmen
wenn das so stimmt der brücker sagt herr
dahm würden sie das sagen sind wir schon
in einer endemischen lage und dann
müsste man doch eigentlich sofort alles
frei also lockern wir sind in einem
übergangsstadium und ich glaube das gilt
es auch anzuerkennen also alle menschen
die im gesundheitswesen arbeiten würden
da jetzt strikt widersprechen würden
sagen die last die jetzt nicht nur in
den letzten zwei jahren dort getragen
wurde sondern auch ganz konkret in
vielen kliniken im moment noch besteht
es ist ja ein irrglaube dass man sich
vorstellen muss dass menschen die
beispielsweise ganz offensichtlicher
maßen mit anderen erkrankungen aber
zusätzlich auch infiziert dort behandelt
werden nicht unglaublich viel aufwand
bedeuten an schutzmaßnahmen an isolation
all das führt dazu dass im
gesundheitswesen nach wie vor eine sehr
hohe belastung da ist völlig unbenommen
dass es insgesamt natürlich gelungen ist
durch eine höhere impfquote durch das an
schutzmaßnahmen was gerade die
ungeimpften im moment noch sehr gut in
deutschland vor einer infektion schützt
die lage besser unter kontrolle zu
bringen als das in der vergangenheit der
fall war und insofern begeben wir uns
jetzt schrittweise in eine neue phase
und ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir
einen guten frühling und guten sommer
bekommen werden aber wir sollten
vorsichtig sein ein geordnetes geplante
schrittweises vorgehen und jetzt nicht
durch planlose verstolperte lockerungen
alles kaputt machen was wir uns
gemeinsam erarbeitet haben
wenn wir aber sagen wir trauen uns bei
incidents und von 1400 zu lockern jetzt
im nachhinein würden sich sagen wir
hätten einfach doch viel früher lockern
müssen wir hatten ja früher gab es ganz
andere instanzen wichtig ist ja zunächst
mal wie gehen wir an die dinge heran und
der unterschied ist nicht die frage dass
man natürlich nicht willkürlich
irgendwelche kalendarischen daten
festlegt sondern dass es nach fakten
nach erkenntnissen gehen muss der punkt
ist aber wer hat die begründung lässt
und dass wir ein datum festgelegt haben
für ein auslaufen von tiefgreifenden
regelung beruht genau darauf dass die
eben nicht neue normalität sind sondern
dass der rechtsstaat begründen muss
warum er in die freiheitsrechte von
bürgern eingreift und deshalb würde ich
da einen gewissen unterschied zu reinen
dame neben sehen und sagen nicht die
lockerung müssen begründet werden nach
irgendwelchen erkenntnissen umgekehrt
freiheitseinschränkung bedürfen der
rechtfertigung nicht die ausübung von
grundrechten ist in unserem rechtsstaat
begründung bedürftig sondern der
eingriff in die rechte und oder start um
jetzt ist das ist das datum wenn du das
infektionsschutzgesetz ausläuft am
neunzehnter werden wenn das jetzt am 15
märz ausgelaufen dann hätte man es dann
gemacht also das ist doch auch sehr
willkürlich gegriffen ja gut da gab es
eben modellierung und ich würde mich da
auch zu deutlich zum team augenmaß 10 es
gab ja leute die immer zum immer zu den
diversen szenarien bevorzugt haben um
ihre dinge zu begründen das ist ja auch
schön wenn sich jetzt manches als
besserer herausstellt als manche
optimistischen modellierung selbst waren
was jetzt gerade das abnehmen der
inzidenz angeht aber umso wichtiger ist
es doch da jetzt konsequent zu sein
nachdem zwanzigster märz kann es kann es
nicht generell einfach weiter maßnahmen
geben auch der begriff basismaßnahmen
darf nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass
jede maßnahme in sich sinnvoll und
begründbar sein muss und deshalb da
kommen wir sicherlich gleich noch das
klingt aber sonderlich auf euer nicht
völlig in die bar gewesen nein sondern
es muss immer natürlich neumann muss ja
zeiträume festlegen wann man wieder
etwas evaluiert und neu begründen muss
und deshalb macht es auch sinn bestimmte
zeiträume oder kollegen aber die sind
die dürfen nicht willkürlich sein dass
es völlig klar aber es gibt ja leute
auch in der politik in deutschland die
wollten ganz andere zeiträume oder die
wollten zu befristen insofern das ist
eine begründungspflicht und ich sehe da
kaum noch begründungen für maßnahmen
aber haben wir glaube ich widersprechen
herz der brücke und dann montgomery
bitte herr bürger also liebe fort heute
lieber
wenn die begründungspflicht und sie
haben völlig recht vor teuteberg
entscheidend ist dass man eben
freiheitseinschränkende maßnahmen
begründet dann wird das natürlich auch
jetzt sofort und dann müssen wir über
die fakten und über die zahlen reden ich
finde das auch immer so unfair her damit
sie sagen ja wir dürfen jetzt nicht
willkürlich und planlos einfach alles
auf man das sagt doch keiner es
bestreitet doch auch keiner die
belastung von intensiv pflegen aber es
gibt keine überlastung wir haben eine
niedrige sterblichkeit wir haben
zurückgehende instanzen wo sogar noch
die inzidenz fragwürdig ist weil wenn
wenn infektions ist immer weitergabe
durchgepustet stattfindet dann kann man
doch auch nicht 2g oder 3g rechtfertigen
man muss sich das nochmal überlegen und
die gesunden menschenverstand
einschalten und dann wenn das alles so
ist und die zahlen daten fakten stimmen
dann müsste man sie eigentlich sofort
abschaffen und mich auf ein datum warten
dass man irgendwann mal eingeführt hatte
weil man halt gesagt hatte märz könnte
das auslaufen der maßnahmen beenden wenn
die fakten jetzt da sind dann ist die
begründungspflicht auch jetzt schon
entfallen dass meine meinung aber wer
hat wir haben ja auch das problem das
wir also oft gar nicht klarer fakten und
daten haben weil wir die nicht so gut
erheben wie wir sie vielleicht eben
müssten
das ist genau der punkt wo ich dann auch
ein brücke wieder mal bitten muss den
gesunden menschenverstand einzuschalten
wenn sie wir wissen dass unsere
hospitalisierung since identen etwa um
den faktor 2 falsch sind das nicht an
der schlechten digitalisierung an der
verzögerung der nachmeldungen wenn wir
sagen wir haben nur 11 prozent der
menschen nämlich knapp 3000 auf
intensivstationen so sind das 3000
menschen zu viel die um ihr leben ringen
es geht nicht nur um den prozentsatz den
anteil sondern es geht darum dass
menschen hier völlig überflüssigerweise
um ihr leben kämpfen müssen und übrigens
mit einer relativ schlechten chance im
vergleich zu anderen erkrankungen
liefern auf intensivstationen sid und
wenn wir jetzt dinge frei geben wofür
ich bin dürfen wir nur eines nicht
vergessen in dem überschwang
all diesen markigen worten die jetzt
kommen wir müssen das dann ersetzen
durch eigenverantwortung weil die
pandemie ist nicht vorbei wir müssen den
menschen klar machen es muss nicht mehr
alles durch zwang sein aber ihr müsst
euch selber der noch daran halten sonst
sind wir im nächsten herbst wieder da wo
wir im letzten herbst aber diese eigene
verantwortung für teutenberg aber die
könnte hätte man doch den bürgern schon
vorher geben können oder das verstehe
ich jetzt auch nicht ich glaube wir da
jetzt redlich argumentieren dann gehört
doch auch dazu dass die gesetzlichen
grundlagen auf bundesebene den rahmen
sind der auch vor ort und in den ländern
auch unterschiedlich dann angewendet
wird abhängig von der lage es ist ja
jetzt nicht so dass durch ein
bundesgesetz immer bis ins detail
feststeht welche maßnahme in welchem
bundesland oder welchem landkreis gerade
gilt insofern macht es schon sinn von
gewissen zeitraum bestimmte gesetzliche
grundlagen zu schaffen und dann muss
immer noch übrigens gerechtfertigt
werden können ob das in der jeweiligen
region bestimmte einzelne anordnung
gerechtfertigt sind aber das
entscheidende ist doch erst mal diese
begründungspflicht und da habe ich jetzt
er erlebt in der debatte in unserem land
in den letzten monaten und zwei jahren
das oft die rechtfertigung last genau
umgedreht wird wir haben vor ein paar
wochen in diesem land darüber diskutiert
dass manche meinten es sei jetzt die
große mangelnde vorsicht dass man nicht
die nationale epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite verlängert und
tatsächlich schon mal das auf eine etwas
andere grundlage stellt jetzt plötzlich
wird es schon in frage gestellt dass man
überhaupt diese grundlage sagte also mir
geht es um die logik und die wird in der
politik da sehe ich aber in gefahr
wirklich auch für unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung in der
debattenkultur dass es schick geworden
ist jegliche art von freiheit und von
eintreten für grundrechte als irgendwie
gewissenlos als leichtfertig imbiss
stück weit zu diffamieren und ich glaube
da müssen wir wieder zu der rechtsstaat
ich ja nicht jetzt sagt der
bundeskanzler hat gesagt irgendwie haben
wir das nach zwei jahren mal verdient
ich glaube viele leute hatten auch nach
einem jahr schon das gefühl dass sie mal
was verdient haben also wenn man sich
vorstellt wie viele menschen also frauen
die sich um ihre kinder kümmern home
office und alles gleichzeitig machen
müssen ich glaube da hatten viele auch
das gefühl das hätten sie sich vorher
schwache dient
das kann doch kein argument sein
eigentlich keinen grund dass wir das mal
verdient hätten genauso ist es ist auch
nicht das argument war sehr im
vordergrund steht sondern klar es ist
sozusagen das virus hält sich nicht an
kalender oder an datum sondern es hält
uns weltweit seit zwei jahren in atem
und hat einen verheerende folge an
schweren erkrankungen todesfolgen
hervorgerufen wir müssen auch
feststellen dass es zwar jetzt in dieser
mikrowelle so ist das insbesondere
geimpfte und genesene
weniger schwer krank werden und das ist
vor allem ungeimpfte betrifft und wir
sicherlich auch sehen dass wir milde
verläufe haben aber das ist nach wie vor
keine milde erkrankungen wir sehen nach
wie vor viele schwere verläufe wir haben
seit dem 27
januar erlebt dass wir ein anstieg der
hospitalisierung 's rate haben wir haben
wieder eine zunahme der neuaufnahmen auf
den intensivstationen gesehen das heißt
also mir ist schon wichtig auch zu
widersprechen zu sagen schutzmaßnahmen
die uns jetzt gut durch die letzten
wochen gebracht haben die war nicht
unbegründet zu keinem zeitpunkt sondern
es gab immer eine grundlage sehr
eindeutig also in der situation die hier
war dienen den nachbarländern sichtbar
waren dies erforderlich gemacht haben
das anzuwenden und jetzt sind wir in der
neuen situation und genau wie situation
weil wir diesen peak überschritten haben
von omikron oder warum genau genau wir
sind in der situation dass wir sehen
dass die neue infektionszahlen nicht
mehr weiter ansteigen und das auch auf
den intensivstationen wie ein plateau
erreicht haben also steigt nicht weiter
an und wenn wir sagen das war einmal der
punkt wo wir gesagt haben wenn wenn die
neue infektionszahlen nicht weiter
ansteigen wenn wir keinen rasanten
anstieg in der belastung des
gesundheitswesen weiter sehen dann sind
wir an dem punkt dass wir in einem
gestuften und schrittweise verfahren
auch öffnung schritte voran immer die
frage das was der brücker gesagt warum
dann nicht sofort öffnen warum sage ich
da jetzt nicht ab morgen ist alles immer
so wie in anderen ländern auch von einem
auf den anderen tag einfach alle
maßnahmen fallen weil eine pandemie und
einer erkrankung ja nicht aufhört in dem
moment wo ein medikament anfängt zu
wirken sondern sozusagen eine eine die
das bekämpfen einer pandemie erfordert
ja genauso wie wir in der behandlung
eines patienten dass man die dosierung
anpasst dass man maßnahmen zurücknimmt
und so ist es auch in der situation dass
wir sagen weil wir sehen dass die
maßnahmen wirken sind die maßnahmen
nicht um sinnvoll sondern im gegenteil
sie haben ihren zweck erfüllt und die
die form der dosierung wie viel wir
brauchen wir schützen müssen das müssen
wir angepasst jetzt an die situation wo
ich wirkung zeigt ist übrigens mal eine
klarstellung wichtig werden würde eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aber über
gesetze und grundrechtseingriffe
entscheidet nach unserer verfassung auch
immer noch das parlament das bedeutet
übrigens auch dass das jetzt ein
gewisser fahrplan ist aber tatsächlich
wird der deutsche bundestag beraten
müssen und auch entscheiden müssen
insofern ist es schön und gut und
wichtig dass sich auch länder
beschäftigen
aber vielleicht hat man sich auch daran
in dieser pandemie schon viel zu sehr
gewöhnt dass so ein paar runden von
regierungschefs er vermeintlich
bestimmen welche maßnahmen jetzt genau
ergriffen werden also insofern hat sich
über einen bestimmten bestimmten pfad
verständigt aber trotzdem müssen
letztendlich parlamente jetzt nochmal
genau abwägen und entscheiden was wird
weitergeführt und was wird jetzt auch
ersatzlos abgeschafft und das ist
wichtig dass auch nicht zu vergessen
herr montgomery wenn man es aber
vergleichbar sie haben die als welt
ärzteverband ja nun die welt der auch im
blick also eine andere länder machen ist
ja anders sie sind ja viel klarer die
sagen haben wir machen jetzt auf gleich
machen unseren freedom day und dann ist
gut also wie wie sehen sie das denn wir
sehen sie da deutschland im vergleich zu
den anderen
also ich glaube wir können uns in
deutschland jetzt diese lockerung und
durchaus leisten aber der freedom day
zum beispiel in dänemark dänemark hat
heute wieder dieselbe hohe todesrate wie
sie auf dem gipfelpunkt der zweiten
welle im januar 20 21 gehabt haben also
insofern das ist alles wird chancen aber
auch mit risiken verbunden und der
bundestag der soll ja nur über eine
verlängerung im infektionsschutzgesetz
oder ein anderes gesetz mit dem man
bundesrechtliche etwas regelt
diskutieren der soll jetzt nicht jeder
einzelne
freigabe
wo kämen wir denn da hin zu reden wäre
das dann ja genauso wie wir die
impfpflicht zerredet haben und deswegen
glaube ich hier muss man wirklich die
kirche im dorf lassen dass sie solchen
schutzmaßnahmen pandemischer maßnahmen
ich glaube dass der bundestag sich hier
manchmal ein bisschen zu viel zumutet
also der bundestag der ist für solche
entscheidungen da das ist genauso in
unserem rechtsstaat wichtiger für die
gesellen
entscheidet nicht mehr jeder einzelnen
hat damit der entscheidet aber genau
darüber ob bestimmte eingriffe weiter
eine rechtsgrundlage da ist das ein
unterschied nicht über jede einzelne
maßnahme aber ja das
ist fakt das ist jetzt die rechtslage so
wenn man weitere möglichkeiten über
diesen zeitpunkt hinaus schaffen will
dann muss der deutsche bundestag dafür
eine rechtsgrundlage schaffen und das
ist immer noch seine aufgabe rücker dazu
noch direkt sie heute deutlich haben
selber gesagt redlich wollen wir
diskutieren dann muss man eben auch
sagen es gibt bis zum bis zum 20 märz
alles geregelt durch beschluss des
bundestags was danach ist da sollten sie
beteiligt seien fragen sollte nicht
gerade die frage ist ja nur halten
werden sich die menschen wir haben jetzt
über eigene verantwortung gesprochen wir
hatten in der ganzen corona zeit auch
oft das gefühl dass die bürger verwirrt
waren weil er von bundesland zu
bundesland andere regeln gelten all das
jetzt haben wir eine eine
beschlussvorlage einen beschluss und die
frage ist werden sich bürger noch weiter
daran halten herr brücke oder hat man
nicht jetzt auch das gefühl ja es ist
jetzt eigentlich vorbei und jetzt
brauche ich doch eigentlich nicht mehr
dran zu halten wer will das eigentlich
noch durchsetzen bis zum 20 märz also
zunächst mal ist es für mich zunächst
mal ist für mich wirklich eine neben
debatte ob jetzt der landtag oder der
bundestag die maßnahmen beschließen muss
oder soll das alles wichtig und richtig
mich jetzt erstmal darum auf welcher
grundlage werden politische
einschränkende maßnahmen beschlossen und
ich bezweifele eben dass die
datengrundlage nicht wie sie sagen ja
montgomery zum worst case vielleicht
sogar eigentlich noch viel höher sind
sondern ich bezweifle ich sage das jetzt
zu hoch und ich sage dass die
hospitalisierung incidents im jetzt
schon nicht die richtige kennziffer ist
wenn mir chefärzte sagen von kliniken
das sind ärzte das eigentlich zwei
drittel ihrer intensivpatienten halt
auch kurve positiv sind aber wegen
völlig andere sachen im krankenhaus sind
und die ohnehin auch im krankenhaus
gewesen wären und sie auch auf der
intensivstation gelandet werden dann ist
für mich dass keine richtiges kriterium
genauso wie die hohe inzidenz wenn wenn
eine an wenn ein virus sehr ansteckend
ist aber es kaum krank macht und von
geburten und von geimpften weitergegeben
werden kann dann rechtfertigt es nicht
diese maßnahmen das ist doch nur mein
punkt ich komme immer wieder zurück zu
den maßnahmen und nicht wer was
entscheidet und die die aussage von olaf
scholz die ist doch wirklich der witz
des tages es geht doch nicht darum ob
ich mich wohl fühle und ob wir es
verdient haben die diese corona pandemie
zu wenden das ist so eine unsinniges
argument es geht darum rechtfertigen
diese maßnahme aufgrund der kriterien
die wir festgelegt haben und zwar die
politik diese einschränkung ich bin der
meinung inzwischen wirklich langsam
nicht mehr im gegenteil es ist peinlich
was wir für daten wo luther eigentlich
als grundlagen für einschränkende
freiheitseinschränkende maßnahmen und
dann kommt karl lauterbach daher und
sagt ja vielleicht haben aber vier oder
fünf 100 tote am tag völlig unbegründet
völlig unplausibel auf keiner
wissenschaftlichen dafür kassieren das
ist etwas was es in israel gesehen drei
holen das ist doch wohl jeden tag ein
großraumflugzeug was da ab stürzt weil
das ist ja schon so nicht aber dann
redet er über vier ja natürlich der mann
komme jeden tag sterben menschen in
deutschland wegen ganz und das ist auch
schlimm der virus ist auch schlimm es
ist doch nur die frage der
verhältnismäßigkeit
lauterbach hat von 400 bis 500 toten am
tag geredet in einer zeit da hatten wir
80 bis 100 ich verstehe nicht warum
warum die worst case szenarien grundlage
sind auch drei seiner die lage ist aber
dann müssen wir konsequent sein und das
härter machen man komme damit können sie
es uns darin steigen würde steigen würde
vernünftiges gleichgewicht
wir haben ein vernünftiges verhältnis
will sie ihr verhältnis inzwischen der
von herrn brückner geforderten
verhältnismäßigkeit bin ich ja im kern
bei ihm wenn auch nicht in der sprache
und in der intensität und gleichzeitig
müssen uns aber auch dagegen wehren dass
er so floskeln bringt wie das ist doch
gar nicht so schlimm als erkrankungen
dies ist nach wie vor eine tödliche
erkrankung die ihn soll ich kann die
sorgen bei uns nämlich müssten gesagt
vor einem prozent hat doch sie tun so
als ob das eine ganz einfache kleine
kammer wenn eine wie sie zu dieser
tätigkeit hat er keine mehr kommen und
herr brücke haben den pharisäern oder
verhandelt der hobbykoch 15 ich glaube
das ist uns entschuldigen sie ich hab
selber gehabt aber ich hab selber gehabt
und ich hatte keinen milden verlauf ich
habe selber gehabt ich habe keinen
milden verlauf gehabt ich hatte es in
der ersten welle ich rede von der fall
sterblichkeit das sind rk ii zahlen das
ist 0,15 prozent bei der aktuelle
mikrowelle im vergleich zu den früheren
varianten ich rede nur über die fakten
vom rk ii und dann sage ich rechtfertigt
das noch die maßnahmen mehr sage ich
nicht gesagt
ja ok kommen wir noch mal dazu was das
jetzt also wie wir da jetzt mit umgehen
sollen dann wenn wir auch weiter hohe
todeszahlen haben kommt dann irgendwann
punkt wo wir sagen jetzt haben wir
gelockert aber irgendwie funktioniert es
nicht in jetzt müssen das wieder
zurücknehmen geht es dann nein wir
können ja im moment nur ausgehend von
der aktuellen situation sagen dass wir
feststellen können dass trotz hohen
infektionszahlen wir keinen rasanten
anstieg der
neuaufnahmen in den kliniken sehen und
auf den intensivstationen wir haben
immer noch sehr viele patienten die dort
behandelt werden müssen wir müssen das
weiter sehr ernst nehmen und ich warne
davor den eindruck zu erwecken das sei
eine erkrankung mit lappalien wohl nur
noch ein paar wenige menschen krank
werden das entspricht nicht den
tatsachen
es ist weiter eine tödliche erkrankung
und die die sie hochbetagt mit
vorerkrankung betrifft insbesondere
ungeimpften das ist eine sehr große zahl
in unserem land die werden schwer krank
und
den müssen wir auch als tatsache
entgegentreten und das zur grundlage
gemacht es bedeutet das jetzt bedeutet
konkret für die nächsten wochen wir
können mit dem was sowie die situation
ist jetzt schrittweise schutzmaßnahmen
zurückbauen und wir werden sehen dass
das hoffentlich auch trägt in denen das
frühjahr hinein dass die fallzahlen und
auch die neuaufnahmen im
gesundheitswesen nicht wieder so stark
ansteigen
das bedeutet aber nicht dass die
pandemie vorbei ist sondern es kann
durchaus sein dass wir im weiteren
verlauf durch neue virusvarianten durch
die herbst winter saison wieder in eine
situation kommen wo wir zusätzliche
schutzmaßnahmen brauchen wenn wir uns
nicht anders beispielsweise durch eine
höhere immunisierung quote mit einer
besseren impfung schützen in einer
kleinen guck mal da man genau konkret
darauf was das eben für den herbst dann
bedeuten können sie sagen wir brauchen
eine höhere impfquote und die kriegen
wir nur durch eine impfpflicht da reden
wir gleich noch mal über ihre argumente
der frau teuteberg sie sagen ja sie
möchten keine impfpflicht wie viel
schützen sie sich dafür davor oder wie
wollen sie die bevölkerung davor
schützen wenn es eine neue variante gibt
wenn es auf einmal höhere infektion
wieder gibt also was machen sie dann
wenn sich eine frau als einschränkungen
wollen und auch keine impfpflicht ja das
ist ja keine frage von schwarz-weiß
alles oder nichts und keine keine
maßnahmen sondern anders auch als herr
montgomery gerade angedeutet hat
zunächst mal der
verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsatz unserer
verfassung der gilt uneingeschränkt der
gilt für jeden und es keine frage des
bebens sondern man muss ihnen ausfüllen
und bei der bei der prüfung was ist
verhältnismäßig und was nicht natürlich
die jeweils aktuellen erkenntnisse und
daten in dieses wie eine mathematische
gleichung mit mehreren unbekannten und
da muss man die richtigen daten
einsetzen so zu sagen haben wir ja den
problemen und unsere genau das ist das
leben des autors rechnet aber nach
unserer verfassung nicht dass man immer
von irgendwelche worst-case-szenarien
annimmt und dann sozusagen vom
schlimmstmöglichen ausgeht und dann sagt
jetzt müssen wir alles ergreifen sondern
man muss den eingriff in ein
freiheitsrecht mit dem ziel das man
erreichen will und auch der
plausibilität der wirksamkeit der
maßnahme die man dafür vorschlägt wird
sagen in abwägung bringen und sehr
ordentlich aus nicht dass man durch eine
impfpflicht eine höhere impfquote
bekommt also zunächst mal ist schon das
fraglich in der praktischen wirkung
einerseits übrigens als vorbemerkung
viele unserer europäischen nachbarn
zeigen dass man ohne eine allgemeine
impfpflicht durchaus eine höhere
impfquote erreichen kann als wir sie
jetzt haben dann kommt aber übrigens das
thema daten hinzu auch das lka selbst
sagt ja dass die reale impfquote
durchaus etwas höher ist als die
prozentsätze die uns regelmäßig genannt
werden weil wir gar nicht die die volle
erfassung der impfung haben wir
bräuchten alle register und dann
vielleicht die unbedingte pflicht es
dass das was sie sagen nicht sagt
erstmal dass es viele andere
möglichkeiten gibt die impfbereitschaft
und das reale vornehmen von impfungen zu
erhöhen dazu gehört haben wir aber näher
menschen zu das rechtfertigt aber auch
nicht jedes mittel das auch übrigens der
grundgedanke das
verhältnismäßigkeitsprinzip also erst
mal ist die frage warum diejenigen
menschen um es praktisch zu machen die
sich tatsächlich hartnäckig einer
impfung verweigern dieser gar nicht für
zu erreichen sind die wird man durch
eine impfpflicht nur weil sie im
bundesgesetzblatt steht nicht erreichen
das ist ja okay dass menschen impfen
lassen aber das wichtig weil da etwas
versprochen was nicht zu halten ist ob
ihr nicht wo ich will allein dadurch
dass wir so klar machen damit wir auch
zu den anderen dossiers ihren mut wenn
sie schwer umzusetzen ist wenn ich nicht
menschen doch dazu bringe freiwillig
sich impfen zu lassen dann erreicht sie
ja auch dieses ziel nicht das heißt die
umsetzungsschwierigkeiten die
unbeantwortet sind die bedeuten bei
lichte besehen doch schon ein problem
für die zielerreichung und damit auch
für die verhältnismäßigkeit ok
politische erwägungen kommen noch hinzu
ok im untertitel ist jemand punkt damit
die anderen auch noch dazu wort kommt
herr montgomery was würden sie sagen ist
die impfpflicht wünschen sie sich das
was sie sagen das ist wenn wir jetzt
lockern ist es umso wichtiger dass wir
sehr schnell eine allgemeine impfpflicht
bekommen damit wir dann die impfquote
erhöhen damit
ja ich würde sagen ja wir haben uns
jetzt seit einem jahr von seinem bart
geredet um die leute vom impfen zu
überzeugen und da gibt es in der tat
heute bergrecht in der hardcore szene
von vielleicht fünf prozent die sich nie
im leben impfen lassen werden aber es
gibt auch noch ungefähr zwanzig prozent
von menschen die in diesem land nicht
geimpft sind die aber eine impfung
wahrnehmen würden wenn man ihnen eine
brücke baut das haben übrigens italien
und frankreich wenn ich mal aus meinem
erfahrungsschatz aus dem weltärztebund
reden darf erfolgreich geschafft dort
sind diese menschen geimpft aber es gibt
auch das gegenbeispiel dänemark hat das
ohne eine impfpflicht geschafft aber
dänemark hat eine digitale infrastruktur
gehabt wir haben immer genau gewusst was
sie machen im gegensatz zu uns und
deswegen sage ich wir müssen die
menschen jetzt mit einer impfpflicht
dazu bringen die die eine brücke gebaut
haben wollen und müssen damit sie sich
impfen lassen denn der kern unseres auf
all dies ist die grundimmunisierung in
der bevölkerung zu einer ganzen
bevölkerung das hinkriegen dann nutzen
wir nicht nur den menschen den
individuell geimpften menschen sondern
nutzen wir auch allen anderen und das
ist eine für mich ausgesprochen sehr
verhältnismäßige freiheits überlegung
nämlich freiheit zum leben und nicht
freiheit zu krankheit und tod brücker
wie sehen sie ist gerade jetzt auch im
hinblick dass man sagt wir lockern und
dafür sagen wir jetzt brauchen wir aber
auch eine impfpflicht damit wir dann
wenn es im herbst wieder stärker wird
damit wir dann besser gewappnet sind
ich verstehe das argument sehr weil wir
zwei winter erlebt haben dass prävention
leider nicht zum teil dieser politik
gehört und wir immer wieder eine
szenarien hineinstolpern die leider
nicht vorbereitet waren ich verstehe
dass man für den herbst etwas machen
will aber die impfpflicht ist der
falsche weg sie ist aus
verfassungsrechtlichen gründen
fragwürdig muss man gar nicht weiter
darauf eingehen sie ist aus politisch
moralischen gründen fragwürdig weil
eineinhalb jahre lang die ganze politik
versprochen hat so etwas kommt nicht und
drittens sie wird einfach aufgrund des
der wirkung des impfstoffs ist es
fragwürdig wir haben eben nicht diese
hohe treffergenauigkeit wir kennen die
varianten nicht es ist eine impfpflicht
auf vorrat bezüglich einer variante die
wir nicht kennen wir wissen nicht genau
ob sie dann wirkt wir erleben heute das
gepolsterte und geimpfte auch die
infektion weitertragen können das sind
doch alles ernsthafte fragwürdig
argumente es gibt ärzte die sagen das
ist leider das falsche mittel und
natürlich kommen die gründe dazu die
frau teuteberg genannt hat erreichen wir
dann die überhaupt die wir dringend
brauchen und letzter punkt not fast 90
prozent der über 60 jährigen sind
geimpft die variable gruppe die seit
zwei jahren im mittelpunkt steht ist
fast durchgehend da die höhere
grundimmunisierung ist ja da war da gibt
es auch eine chinesin regionen also
insofern ich halte sie schlicht für das
falsche politische mitte und verstehen
trotzdem dass wir im herbst eventuell
neue maßnahmen ergreifen müssen aber
dann würde ich mich über gezielte
impfkampagnen und aufklärung auch in den
vierteln oder auch in
bevölkerungsgruppen wo wir probleme
haben freuen anstatt über eine pflicht
ja herr damen jetzt dürfen sie noch mal
ihren mann warum sie dafür sind und
warum sie denken dass uns das im herbst
helfen würde im pflicht weil eigentlich
hatte der bundeskanzler gesagt sie soll
im februar oder märz kommen so schnell
geht es ja nicht also zunächst einmal
will ich gar nicht so sehr als politiker
sondern als arzt widersprechen wenn
unwahrheiten wie die impfstoffe wirken
nicht hier sowie unwidersprochen der
sendung ist er unredlich wir haben die
rohstoffe im moment in der an jetzt
lassen sie mich kurz aussprechen wir
haben mehrere sehr wirkungsvolle
impfstoffe zugelassen wie gut vor
schwerer erkrankung schützen und darum
geht es uns doch es geht uns darum zu
verhindern dass menschen schwer krank
werden auf einer intensivstation im
krankenhaus behandelt werden können und
dort so viele ressourcen binden das
andere notfälle herzinfarkt schlaganfall
dort nicht mehr behandelt werden können
und wenn unser gemeinsames ziel ist dass
wir diese situation nicht in einem
hamsterrad immer und immer wieder
erleben wollen sondern wenn wir
verhindern wollen dass wir in großer
anzahl schwer erkrankte haben menschen
ihr leben verlieren wir in dieser
überlastung situation ist
gesundheitswesen und der gesellschaft
heraus kommen wollen dann gelingt es nur
wenn wir eine höhere immunisierung quote
mit diesen sehr wirkungsvollen
impfstoffen haben und jetzt ist die
frage wenn wir
nach dem stand der wissenschaft muss man
eindeutig sagen dass alle zur verfügung
stehenden impfstoffe gut vor schwerer
erkrankungen zu schützen sie sind in der
frage des transmission schutz also der
übertragbarkeit ja haben sie mit der
eben mit der omicron variante an wirkung
verloren aber sie sind in dem schutz vor
schwerer erkrankung nach dreifacher
impfung sehr wirkungsvoll aber dennoch
alle dem was heute dass das manchmal
leute befürchten dass sie sich dann alle
drei monate impfen das kann anhalt es
gibt auch nach dem stand der
wissenschaft kann man sagen nach
dreifacher impfung beziehungsweise
dreifachen kontakt also auch der
kombination von zwei mal geimpft und
einmal genesen ist man sehr gut vor
schwerer erkrankung geschützt und wenn
man diese wissenschaftlichen fakten
völlig unumstritten sind wenn man die
anerkennt dann dann ist die konsequenz
dessen was wir erreichen müssen dass
sich eine größere anzahl an menschen
impft weil nur dann kommen wir in diesem
zustand dass nicht eine überlastung
eintritt und da ist die frage der
ausweitung von imf angeboten der
aufklärungsarbeit begleitet durch klare
regeln dessen was wir brauchen um dahin
zu kommen ein ganz entscheidender
schritt und deshalb trete ich ein für
diese tolle einer impfpflicht von 18 zu
kombinieren eben mit aufklärungsarbeit
intensivierung und ausweitung der im
kopf es gibt auch einen anderen antrag
der sagt eine impfpflicht ab 50 auch aus
ihrer fraktion auf der fdp es gibt ein
von der union soll es geben der sagt wir
machen so seine vorbereiten die
impfpflicht und wenn es dann so kommt
dass wir sie brauchen dass man sie dann
dass man dann diesen antrag hat herr
brücke einsatz dürfen sie und dann und
frau heute ja ja weil das ist wirklich
man kann ja ich verstehe diese diese
theorie der politik manchmal unterstellt
menschen dass sie etwas gesagt habe was
ich nicht gesagt habe das ist niemand
sei es dass diese jedoch anerkannte
fakten aber wenn eine impfpflicht moment
ernst kurz zu diesen einsatz kam das
haben sie mir gerade unterstellt habe
ich gar nicht gesagt wenn aber eine
impfpflicht eingeführt wird dann muss
die begründung natürlich sein dass diese
impfpflicht 90 95 prozent und sie
brauchen nur in den antrag schauen von
frau teuteberg wo übrigens auch die
grünen-politikerin tabea rößner
unterschrieben hat da steht glasklar
drin die impf wirkung ist ist gut bei 70
75 78 prozent aber wollen eine
impfpflicht 1 führt dann muss man höhere
prozentsätze wie bei masern wie bei
pocken eben zeigen können damit damit es
auch verfassungsrechtlich sauber ist das
ist nicht mal mein punkt ich habe immer
gesagt dass eine impfung nicht wirkt je
nach freudenberg sie haben ja für die
einrichtung bezogene impfpflicht
gestimmt das ist richtig ja sie haben
dem zugestimmt das heißt sie sind dafür
dass das krankenschwester pflegepersonal
dass die verpflichtet werden sich zu
impfen wie passt das zu ihrem freiheiten
gedanken und dem freiwilligen gedanken
dazu also zum einen abgesehen davon dass
das unter den delta varian bedingungen
diese dieser beschluss zustande kam
nicht auch da durchaus schon auch
praktische probleme gesehen habe ist
gehört zur verhältnismäßigkeit natürlich
schon dass es auch sinnvoll sein kann
abzustufen und dass unsere verfassung
verlangt auch gleich wesentlich gleiches
gleich und auch wesentlich ungleiches
ungleich zu behandeln ich habe durchaus
freiheitseinschränkung für das hat noch
nicht selbst habe ich überall nicht
bestritten eben genau aber trotzdem ist
natürlich der umgang mit besonders
schutzbedürftigen menschen für die einem
mögliche infektion besondere folgen
hätte erstmal ein sachlicher
differenzierungs grund omikron
allerdings macht die sache sehr viel
problematischer und schwieriger jetzt
weil natürlich auch da die impfung
allein nicht als schutz jetzt reicht die
übertragung ist trotzdem möglich das
schafft viele praktische probleme die
man auch sehen muss aber ich will
erstmal diesen gedanken darstellen das
ist wichtig auch zur differenzierung
fähig zu sein das hat ja der wortwechsel
eben auch gezeigt genauso wenig wie die
politik im allgemeinen irgendwas
unterstellt ist es wichtig dass wir alle
differenzieren und ich finde was in der
pandemie viel zu wenig passiert ist mal
ehrlich damit umgehen was wir wissen und
was wir nicht wissen und dazu gehört wir
wissen dass die impfung vor schweren
krankheitsverläufen sehr gut schützt und
deshalb sage ich auch ganz klar dass sie
für die allermeisten menschen sehr
empfehlenswert ist und ich da sind wir
uns selbst ist vollständig geimpft mehr
und trotzdem verstellt mir das nicht den
blick dafür dass unsere verfassung davon
ausgeht dass in der regel erwachsene
menschen selbst darüber entscheiden ob
man ihnen medizinische eingriffe
vorgenommen werden und eine impfung ist
durchaus ein medizinischer eingriff und
es gibt unterschiede zwischen der
derzeitigen corona impfung die für viele
menschen sehr sinnvoll sehr segensreich
ist und den bekannten impfung gegen
masern trocken und andere die einen
dauerhaften schutz bieten und
tatsächlich diese infektion dauer dann
auch ausrotten und dieses ziel ist im
moment nicht erreichbar
deshalb ist mir wichtig dass ihr
sozialen nicht die sehnsucht nach
einfachen lösungen auch da bedienen
indem wir etwas versprechen das nicht
erreichbar ist sondern auch mal sagen
manchmal ist das glas halb voll es gibt
einen schutz gegen für die meisten
menschen gegen schwere erkrankungen und
der fed ist das auch gut dass wir diesen
schutz haben und trotzdem rechtfertigt
es nicht dass man das menschen
vorschreibt sondern wir müssen anderes
tun da es ganz viel luft nach oben
übrigens mal mit einer impfkampagne die
kopf und herz erreicht die ein bisschen
kreativer ist als dieses
ein beispiel und auch vieles andere muss
hinzukommen wir müssen auch so ehrlich
sein dass in vielen bereichen testen
dann zusätzlich notwendig ist um den
schutz zu gewährleisten weil unsere
jetzigen erkenntnisse sagen omikron ist
weiter übertragbar all das müssen wir
ehrlich kommuniziert herr montgomery
visier fürchten sie dass jetzt durch die
durch die lockerungen leute noch weniger
die jetzt noch nicht geimpft sind dass
sie noch weniger denke ich muss mich
impfen lassen weil ihr der eindruck
entsteht ja wir sind irgendwie wir sind
durch mit der pandemie
wäre dann
besonders wichtig ist ja
das ist der eine punkt dass sie die
menschen meinen wir sind durch der
zweite punkt ist aber auch dass das wir
ja auch durchaus ein kleines bisschen
die impfpflicht und diese zweig
einschränkung und eligius diskutiert
haben unter dem oder den versuch
menschen zu überzeugen sich impfen zu
lassen damit sie eben ins ins restaurant
oder ins kino gehen konnten das hat aber
nicht hundertprozentig funktioniert und
die gefahr die sehe ich durchaus und
ford heute bei hat völlig recht
innovativ nach oben bist ganz viel offen
was die kampagnen angela waren sollen
nun nicht so tun als ob es in
deutschland noch jemanden gebe der nicht
vom impfen gehört hätte und der noch
nicht die chance gehabt hätte sich
impfen zu lassen also ihr verdummung ja
die bevölkerung wenn wir so tun als ob
das alles analphabeten werden die nichts
hören und nichts sehen und deswegen sage
ich wir müssen alles tun um die menschen
davon zu überzeugen vom segensreichen
wert der impfung wir dürfen das nicht
zerreden indem wir sagen also wenn es
nur 70 oder 80 prozent sind übrigens
sind es 95 prozent bei den männern an
impfstoffen und nicht 70 oder 80 dann
reicht da schon nicht mehr unter
verhältnismäßigkeit gründen da fühlen
sich die leute doch veräppelt wir wollen
leben retten wir wollen menschen davor
schützen dass sie so krank werden und da
muss man auch an ich war an sich sondern
mit seinen freiheitsrechten auch mal ein
bisschen pflichten übernehmen für andere
muss sich impfen lassen auch wenn es
denn am ende vielleicht nur bei neuen
varianten zu 70 oder 80 prozent hilft
wir tun das doch alles wir wollen doch
keinen menschen mit gewalten spritze den
arm rahmen sondern wir wollen die
menschen vor schweren erkrankungen
bewahren das ist doch der sinn der
ganzen angelegenheit trotzdem in dieser
ganzen coruna pandemie ist ja eine sache
nicht wirklich perfekt gelaufen ist
natürlich auch schwierig wenn man es
eben vorher nicht weiß wie das
funktioniert mit so einer pandemie damit
ist die kommunikation und viele bürger
fühlten sich eben nicht gut mitgenommen
war
viele haben dann gesagt wir brauchen
karl lauterbach als gesundheitsminister
jetzt haben wir karl lauterbach als
gesundheitsminister und höre mir das
okay der herrgott hat er macht es gut
wir sind mit den mit der spd in einer
koalition mit den grünen über die fdp
auch sagen sie jeder ist das jetzt ein
punkt wo man sagt ja dadurch hat das
seither lauterbach den den job hat geht
es in der richtige richtung ich glaube
es ist völlig unrealistische
erwartungshaltung zu haben es gibt den
ein super minister der alle probleme
macht es gibt die eine maßnahme die die
pandemie beendet geht dann sollte die
angst minister die das eine datum an da
ist alles gut ich glaube zu ehrlicher
kommunikation gehört doch auch dazu dass
man dinge nach dem stand der aktuellen
wissenschaft kommuniziert dass man klar
macht es gibt immer nur ein ein set von
mehreren maßnahmen was zusammen eine
wirksamkeit erzeugt so wie es auch in
der medizin in der behandlung von
krankheiten nie nur eine pille gibt die
alles gut macht ja und an der stelle ist
es so dass ich auch nach vorne geschaut
sage es geht doch jetzt darum wenn wir
um die debatte einer impfpflicht reden
vorsorge zu treffen damit wir rauskommen
aus dem hand damit wir im nächsten
herbst nicht einen neuen herbst und
pandemie winter erleben mit entsprechend
hohen zahlen und dieses vorausschauende
vorsorgen was ja in dem vorschlag den
ich als gesetzesvorschlag geht es mit
vorbereitet habe auch beinhaltet dass
wir die vielkritisierte datengrundlage
verbessern also dass menschen jetzt
ihren impfnachweis oder genesene
nachweis
ausweisen und wir im besten fall im
sommer da stehen dass wir eine
datengrundlage haben zu sagen wir
brauchen im herbst gar keine sanktionen
weil bereits die genesenen und im quote
so hoch ist in verbindung mit
aufklärungsarbeit und der ausweitung von
imf angeboten dass das alles sich
erübrigt dass wir das gesetz auflösen
aber wer erhebt das dann herr heute hat
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat dem rk
ii die befugnis entzogen die genesenen
status festzulegen das irritiert die
menschen ja auch das ist anscheinend
kein vertrauen gibt so geschäfte des rk
ii gelder der der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat im übrigen
im einklang mit den koalitionspartnern
und auch bund und ländern dafür gesorgt
dass das was vom bundes
verfassungsgericht im urteil zur
einrichtung bezogenen endlich kritisiert
wurde nämlich das dass es nicht
ausreicht durch eine nachgelagerte
behörde auf einer internetseite
bestimmte regeln die gesetzescharakter
haben auszuweisen sondern dass das im
verordnungswege durch den minister
passieren muss dass das auch wieder
geschieht das haben wir auch in der
koalition zur grundlage gemacht und das
wird jetzt umgesetzt das hat aber nichts
damit zu tun dass wir sehr wohl in
deutschland in der lage sind genesenen
und im zertifikate auszustellen zu
erheben und damit auch eine impfquote zu
messen und auszuweisen die zeigt wo wir
den tatsächlich stehen und ich will ja
gar nicht ausschließen dass das was frau
heute bürger sagt dass wir durch eine
noch mal bessere aufklärungskampagne
durch eine ausweitung von imf angeboten
die wir jetzt ganz neu auch in apotheken
machen wir vielleicht im herbst der im
frühling jetzt sehr erfolgreich sind und
im herbst gar keine weiteren maßnahmen
brauchen aber erst wenn das haus im
herbst wieder trend zu sagen jetzt wäre
es doch gut eine feuerwehrwache zu bauen
dann ist es zu spät wir müssen jetzt
entsprechend reagieren sie reagieren
deshalb sind sie jetzt für die
allgemeine impfpflicht herr brücke als
politischer beobachter wie würden sie
sagen schlägt sich der
bundesgesundheitsminister und ist er
derjenige der die der die bevölkerung
ist in diese freiheit führen kann
richtig oder weil er würde ja auch als
als heran als minister als angst
minister kritisiert schon
also wie gesagt es kommt darauf an
welche maßstäbe wie ein politik anlegen
meine wären jedenfalls
nachvollziehbarkeit transparent und auch
politische glaubwürdigkeit der mann ist
unbestritten kompetent ich finde er es
auch er geht wirklich wissenschaftlich
vor und alles wunderbar aber diese
geschichte mit dem mit dem genesenen
status ist nun genau nicht so wie er
damals gerade geschrieben hat die
parlamentarische staatssekretärin sagt
im bundestag wir werden auf drei monate
gehen am samstag darauf wird verändert
das rk ii die das auf der website und
karl lauterbach sagte im interview ich
bin völlig überrascht worden das war
nicht abgesperrt seiner kinder verloren
hat drei nutzer hat drei tage vor dem
bundestag in sein herz leider nicht
mitbekommen also das hilft nicht für
wahrhaftigkeit und transparenz und
nachvollziehbarkeit wenn da so ein chaos
herrscht und der wichtigste
behördenleiter offenbar nicht das
vertrauen des gesundheitsministers
genießt das finden kein gutes zeichen
okay sie kann man so und so sehen
wahrscheinlich würde ich wahrscheinlich
will keiner sehen würde ich anders aber
wir sind am ende dieser sendung und ich
befürchte es ist nicht die letzte
sendung zum thema krone auch wenn wir
darüber gesprochen haben dass das leben
etwas leichter werden wird zumindest ab
dem 20 märz vielen dank herr dahm für in
der friedeburg herr montgomery herr
brücker vielen danke ihnen fürs
zuschauen hier geht es weiter bei
phoenix der tag und da wären sie
sicherlich auch noch mal die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit allen
beschlüssen bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]